what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and we are now in the Multiverse Saga
which means anything literally anything
is possible in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe which leaves the door open for
very exciting possibilities that could
happen story-wise in the MCU and one of
these stories that is rumored to happen
could be literally insane and fans would
freak out about if this actually does
come true it would basically be giving
us what we wanted from Doctor Strange in
the Multiverse of Madness true
Multiverse Madness many of us including
myself went into the movie expecting
well a lot more madness than we actually
got we expected Doctor Strange to travel
through a lot more universes and we
expected him to stay in some of these
universes for a lot longer than he did
and we also expected to see other
characters from these other universes to
see variants of the characters we know
and love well we now know that Marvel
was basically teasing us and basically
everything we wanted from this movie
well we're going to get in Phase six and
that could possibly include Superior
Iron Man however we might not get him in
the way that we thought we were going to
get him and he might not be so friendly
here's something that I think is going
to be very important in the MCU moving
forward that I don't think a lot of
people have really thought about when it
comes to the Multiverse yes there are
great possibilities for team-ups and
Kevin feige the president of Marvel
Studios has already mentioned that Kang
is not only going to be fighting our
Avengers but he is going to be fighting
other kings as well which means other
Kang's other variants of Kings which we
know are going to team up with each
other since we know that the Council of
Kings is a thing well all of those other
kangs are also going to be fighting the
Avengers so there's a little bit of a
war triangle here Kang will be fighting
the other kings but Kang will also be
fighting the Avengers The Avengers will
be fighting Kang but also the other
kings as well not just one main king and
the Council of Kings will fight the one
exiled king or the Supreme King angler
Prime came whichever you'd like to call
him that is going to rise up and be the
main big bad and they're also going to
fight The Avengers most people know this
and that alone is extremely exciting to
think about a big scene where all of
these people are fighting each other and
a lot of people assume that our Avengers
and our heroes are going to travel
through the Multiverse recruiting other
Heroes to join the fight and help them
defend the Multiverse now that is
absolutely going to happen and we are
going to see some great team ups here
however one thing that a lot of people
aren't thinking about is that some
Heroes might not want to get involved in
fact they could see the other Heroes as
aggressive and hostile much like what we
saw in Multiverse Madness the Illuminati
saw Doctor Strange as the enemy even
though he really wasn't and
unfortunately and I guess spoiler alert
if you haven't seen Multiverse of
Madness yet but unfortunately they all
die they all die because they treated
Steven strange as a hostile when he
really wasn't if they would have just
worked with him they could have lived
but this is a perfect example of what
could happen happen during Secret Wars
and the events leading up to Secret Wars
when we really start to Multiverse
travel you see Marvel's told us
basically enough of what is going to
happen in phase six to where we kind of
know how everything leading up to Kang
Dynasty is going to be basically after
the next Avengers film The Kang Dynasty
that's when we're going to see a lot of
Multiverse travel that's when probably
the new Avengers Secret Wars team is
going to be put together that consists
of Heroes across the Multiverse that's
when we'll get our multiversal team that
comes together in secret Wars to go up
against Kang and the other kings and
that sounds super exciting but there is
a rumor going around that the Earth 838
Universe isn't exactly so happy with our
Steven strange and our universe and
apparently somebody from that Universe
wants the Scarlet Witch now this makes a
lot of sense even when the movie first
came out I said well they made it very
clear that Mr Fantastic was married to
sue storm and they had kids and now
their husband and father was just killed
by the Scarlet Witch you would think Sue
Stone form and Ben Grimm and the Human
Torch would want answers plus not to
mention Mr Fantastic and The Invisible
Woman's kid Franklin Richards grows up
to be an Omega Level mutant possibly the
strongest mutant we've ever seen in the
Marvel Universe he's probably gonna be
pretty upset that Daddy's dead so
definitely people are going to seek
answers and wonder what happened however
there is one person and particularly
that I am thinking about not a superior
Iron Man now we have the Ultron bots in
that Earth 838 Universe which seemed to
be a sign that Superior Iron Man or at
least an Iron Man exist and there was an
open seat all the way to the right in
The Illuminati's Chambers now a lot of
people thought that this was mordo seed
but it wasn't mortal seed was next to
Captain Marvel because he took the spot
of Doctor Strange when he became
sorcerer Supreme so there still was an
open seat all the way to the right and
it would make sense that this could be
Tony Stark especially if he had his
Ultron Bots working at the Baxter
Foundation he was clearly involved with
the Illuminati in some way shape or form
even if he wasn't that actual member but
if you consider the fact that Reed
Richards is the smartest man alive and
Tony Stark is one of the smartest men
alive and they are both in New York it
would make sense that they know each
other especially since Iron Man's
identity as Iron Man is known to
everybody and the same goes with Mr
Fantastic everybody knows that he's Mr
Fantastic so the two of them knowing
each other and working together just
makes sense so somebody from Another
Universe came to our universe and all of
a sudden the entire Illuminati are dead
well Tony Stark's going to seek answers
and since this universe is already well
versed in the Multiverse that means they
probably have a way of traveling the
Multiverse and I'm assuming that there
is some type of footage that Iron Man
can see especially since his Ultron Bots
were the ones fighting the Scarlet Witch
at first before the Illuminati but the
Baxter building was essentially
destroyed and that is obviously
something that is very noticeable and
Iron Man probably flew in right after
the Scarlet Witch left and I'm sure that
he's accessed the footage somehow and
figured out that it is the Scarlet Witch
from Earth 616 who came and did this
killed all of the Illuminati members and
probably killed some of his closest
friends so Tony Stark and people like
the invisible woman and her family the
Fantastic Four they're going to want
answers and most likely Revenge this
could lead to Tony Stark and his Ultron
Army to go to our universe in search of
the Scarlet Witch that is the current
rumor that is out there people from
Earth 838 want revenge for what the
Scarlet Witch did and are going to seek
it so it doesn't specify whether they're
coming to our universe or not what could
happen is that when our heroes from our
Earth start traveling the Multiverse to
recruit other Heroes they could arrive
back at Earth a38 and instead of being
greeted warmly they could be greeted
very hostile-like from people who are
ready to seek revenge on them and do not
care about the Multiverse but only their
Universe because that's how they were
when Doctor Strange arrived they didn't
really ask many questions they kind of
just got together to immediately decide
what they were going to do with them so
we can assume that a very angry Iron Man
or a very angry Fantastic Four and if
they did already reform the Illuminati
angry Illuminati members we can assume
that they won't greet them very well and
they won't really want to talk
especially if this truly is going to be
superior Iron Man he is not exactly the
best guy in the comics he's borderline a
villain so it is very possible that we
could actually end up seeing Superior
Iron Man and we could see him fighting
Our Heroes instead of joining them and
this could be the case multiple times
throughout the Multiverse when our
heroes go to recruit people we can
assume that not all of these heroes are
going to be the same and nice in fact
some Heroes could be villains in some
other universes so I'm guessing that not
every encounter with variants of these
Heroes that we know and love is going to
be peaceful which I think is actually
really cool and I think could really add
to the whole entire story of the multi
Saga they've already established not
every variant is the same in fact many
variants can be completely different
from each other even Kang has good
variants in the comics but I definitely
think that this would add a lot of depth
and a lot of story to the Multiverse
Saga as it is and especially to Secret
Wars and if Earth 83h truly is going to
seek revenge I really do hope it is
superior Iron Man and some members of
the Fantastic Four I think that would be
absolutely insane I hope we see it it's
just a rumor for now but hey let me know
what you think about it in the comments
down below would you like to see this
would you not like to let us know don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest MCU news you can always follow us
on Instagram and Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof